these by pick artists in Montes current
points out that just as there are small
compact cars for city and big ones for
long distance travel trucks have
different models too so what are they
exactly that's a question for suka form
on logan uh mercedes-benz
she says that depends on the kind of
trip drivers who do long-haul are
usually on the road for several days so
they need a comfortable sleeper cab in
the truck with the bed and enough room
where they can stay the night while City
trips on the other hand involves drivers
starting in the morning distributing
their goods and going home at night so
those drivers don't need all those
facilities and that means trucks plying
in the city have smaller more compact
driver cabinets which is better since
they often have to maneuver in smaller
spaces for Tyler for care and it was
even 60 here a father to have a stock of
myungsoo keen can some ranchy own good
so Marcus is now going to test this
Mercedes at ego to see how it performs
its mouth so we head out onto a country
road at a height of around 2 meters
above ground Montes can now try out this
big machine and it's not just his high
vantage point that allows him to get a
good overview
monta says despite his huge size
compared to a car
it isn't really difficult to get a grip
on the ax t go thanks to the six mirrors
mounted around the driver's cabin but
what he'd really like is a camera so
that he can see what's exactly happening
behind the vehicle but during the trip
there's mostly just a line of cars to be
seen in Germany most trunks are limited
to 80 kilometers per hour
while driving the Antigua with a
permissible total weight of 7.5 tonnes
it's a weight category popular around
the world and not just with haulage
firms Montes says that people who got
their card driver's license in Germany
before 1998 are also allowed to drive
seven and a half ton trucks like the
Antigua here that means many people who
usually don't drive a truck can also use
this vehicle for instance when they're
moving
he says the automatic gearbox makes it
easier to get used to the truck because
all you have to do is keep your eyes on
the road
steer brake and accelerate of the
Strasse Kokomo's lengthen on pencil and
Gauss key but you have to be careful
with side winds because of the large
truck as long as you don't load the
truck to its full capacity you don't
have to worry about stability because
the main weight of a truck is centered
around its axles
NIMBY Mota says in addition to the ax t
go there are heavier truck models that
can have a total weight of up to 40 tons
eglee does Mickey Ines Actos but here
too there are special vehicles for long
haul and short haul trips SiC affirm on
Logan says the Mercedes actress model
has sleeper cabs for long haul trips
that are 2 meters 40 wide and have a
uniform floor but that's not needed for
the city when a drivers on the road for
several days he needs to have a feel of
a home for day trips a driver does not
need a sleeper cab with big dimensions
and lots of comfort and this is where
you have tailor-made options she says
bonia of me Sophia come for peated when
here is even design keyboard fit CL
often inside specs waiver for Tyler phu
khao sok is knitting and there are other
requirements for garbage trucks here
getting in and out of the vehicle has to
be made easy as well as turning into
narrow streets
this Mitsubishi Fuso Kanter shows that
trunks don't have to always be big to
transport a lot its compact structure
allows it to carry the biggest load in
its segment and there's also a diesel
hybrid version
as an equal Mota says the Fuzhou cancer
isn't just unbelievably flexible its
hybrid engine is great because you can
save around four litres of diesel on 100
kilometers so after four years you've
got back the additional eight thousand
euros you paid on the price you always
have a ten year guarantee on hybrid
parts it's not a bad deal but Monta says
it remains to be seen if the hybrid
engine can compete with the conventional
diesel version that's ability has not
taken